yo how'd your date go great man thanks I  really like her don't worry guys she  probably doesn't even know how it works  oh my look at all these pictures I just  shut down the Wi-Fi for two city blocks  she's offline no no she just like doing  my status updates from two years ago  it's impossible there's a signal coming  from inside the building she's inside  the building this thing is so slow what  all you can do is tell you uploaded yeah  I just saw your baby drunk man where are  you  I saw your post I just want you to be  safe that's why I'm giving you condoms I  can't help you anymore  why not she told my mom to add me too  but all that he jus hi honey  I just wanted to tell you about  something really sweet that happened  your mom added me on Facebook isn't that  great  [Music]